les cascades des effets spéciaux
j'ai regardé le film d'auteur je suis
désolé Vincent Lindon marche
langoureusement vers Juliette Binoche à
langoureusement on a vidé la salle
si tu remplaces langoureusement par des
ninjas sur la vie de ma mère c'est pas
le même film
Juliette
oui c'est vrai mais
attendez pas cette intervention
c'est également au début de la cérémonie
il y a le sketch d'un médecin et il y a
Drucker qui a été interrompu par une
militante écologiste aussi du déroule
dernière rénovation
[Musique]
fallait que ça tombe sur moi sur la tête
de ma mère fallait que ça tombe sur moi
c'est un délire
[Musique]
bon alors on avait écrit des petites
trucs il y avait des accents italiens
des accents
tu peux arrêter le symbolique pardon on
y retourne
alors on y avait aussi une surprise de
la cérémonie
frère on était comme ça les deux il fait
pas il pétait pas sans m'appeler ma
comme ça c'est un tueur
il a voulu serrer ma daronne
il y avait parce qu'il est
c'est un réalisateur et plein de films
[Applaudissements]
de David Fincher bonsoir Je m'appelle
Brad Pitt et je suis un rescapé
[Applaudissements]
sur maillon c'est éclaté il a fait la
pâte à la maison après il a fait Chabat
à la maison samedi sur ma vie
mon frère
dis-moi il y avait également alors moi
le moment le plus drôle de la soirée
j'ai adoré Jamel
je vais faire le lancement tout seul on
est pas dans le 6 à 7
et mon ami Jérôme comme ça et il a avalé
une amie de la maison
j'ai fait une boulette une toute petite
boulette et une dame toute mignonne dans
la file pour rentrer là vous savez on
est là on sait pas quoi faire
l'instrumentaux dans les mains en
piétine et puis moi gentil je lui dis ah
c'est votre première fois au César me
dit oui je dis vous êtes de la famille
d'un dénommé elle me coupe elle me dit
non Jérôme je suis la ministre de la
Culture
j'ai mais qu'est-ce que tu as fait à tes
cheveux Roselyne tu as tout lycée
elle me dit non je suis celle d'après je
suis après moi j'ai en même temps sans
vous faire offense même la ministre vous
avez une notoriété en devenir voilà non
mais vous n'êtes pas emmerdé quand vous
faites vos courses quoi
on n'est pas prêt de pouvoir chanter à
la mi-temps du Super Bowl
c'est vrai qu'il y a une époque elle va
te décharge au César tout le monde
connaissait Jack Lang se brushing
corbeau noir de Jette chez L'Oréal au
milieu de la salle tout le monde
s'asseyait autour comme des amis je
prenne un feu de bois quand tu es là
chauffer les mains
c'était facile à reconnaître
on peut pas vous faire les on a passé le
weekend à imiter des intervenants de
TPMP
vous allez voir on a croisé du beau
monde tout le gratin du 7e art est passé
derrière du micro avec plus ou moins de
choses à nous dire regardez on y était
et sur tapis rouge on est tombé sur une
farandole d'excuse pour pas répondre au
micro de TPMP on commence avec Virginie
Efira dans un style je m'en balek
Virginie Virginie un petit message pour
Cyril Hanouna
les adrucker qui nous a fait l'excuse du
coup de fil sans le téléphone qui sonne
un petit mot pour Cyril Hanouna
super merci on est tombé sur Juliette
Binoche qui nous a vu comme Voldemort
Juliette est un petit message pour Cyril
Hanouna
pour Cyril Hanouna
on a une charlotte Gainsbourg sauvé par
son attaché de presse Charlotte bonjour
un petit message pour Cyril Hanouna
[Musique]
un petit message pour Cyril Hanouna ça y
est je dois y aller
le frère de Valérie Benaim qui nous aime
mais très rapidement quoi Laurent s'il
vous plaît un petit mot un petit mot
pour Valérie ah oui ça nous ferait
plaisir comment allez-vous ça va très
bien pardon non non c'est pour Valérie
le retour de l'attaché de presse très
pressé audrey elle revient super une
Charlotte Lebon bon qui a pas tout
compris Charlotte bonjour est-ce que
vous auriez un message pour serrer la
Nouna Charles
mais le vent a vite tourné avec Miss
France un petit message pour Cyril
Hanouna pour Cyril
à 5 minutes de la cérémonie on
commençait à toucher au Graal avec Adèle
exarcopoulos un message pour Cyril
Hanouna
et enfin gros exclu pour TPMP une star
américaine a enfin répondu à notre micro
isabelle a un petit message pour Cyril
un petit message quand même où on le
verra jamais et moi je compte beaucoup
sur les humoristes pour pour alléger la
soirée
on embrasse Isabelle bien sûr que j'aime
par contre elle a pas dormi depuis 5 6
ans là
alors on a aussi croisé Jérôme
Commandeur sur le tapis rouge et il
avait un petit message regardez
le matin le soir et l'après-midi
tu peux peut-être le citer ce soir ou
quelque part ça suffit faut il faut il
faut désirer tout ça
alors
il y a Daniel Moreau si qui était
présente sur le tapis rouge à surpris
général on a peut-être réussi à lui
arranger un gros coup avec une grosse
retard regardez
on a trouvé Daniel Moreau qui était pas
trop venu pour le cinéma mais plutôt
pour trouver son cowboy comment
allez-vous je suis super ravi d'être là
franchement
moi je fais la midinette je viens oui je
viens voir toutes ces stars
accompagné j'espère je sais qu'il me
fait craquer Ahmed Sylla ah si tu me
regardes je t'aime toujours autant et
ben justement Daniel on a eu votre
réponse puisqu'on a rencontré un médecin
pas insensible tu vois Daniel ouais te
kiffe de ouf frère est-ce que tu penses
il y a moyen l'argent j'allais la
retrouver elle est partie dans quel sens
tu crois par là
surtout un message pour vous Cyril va
falloir que vous répondiez votre
téléphone mais Cyril viens frère c'est
cette année j'ai je suis là tu es pas là
bon bref tu penses tu peux s'il te plaît
ce qu'il aime trop guster mes appels ça
m'énerve
il a été incroyable très fort très fort
et il y a eu un alors il y a une grosse
info sur le tapis des Césars regardez je
vous laisse regarder on se débrief après
regarder
particularité des Césars cette année on
a une personnalité qui a fait deux fois
le tapis rouge Franck bonjour un petit
message pour Cyril quand même Cyril je
t'aime c'est
Eric je t'adore et hop Marley revient 2
minutes plus tard avec une nouvelle robe
et avec un message pour vous Cyril
est-ce que vous auriez un message pour
Cyril bah je l'ai vu il y a 48 heures
même pas oui c'est vrai on a passé un
bout de la Saint-Valentin ensemble
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait nous en
plus vous lui poserez la question
je t'ai même pas au courant elle me met
au courant de cette affaire non non j'ai
vu on a été prendre un petit verre il y
a pas longtemps
l'après-midi attention avec Marlène
Schiappa et c'est vrai que on a on a
très on a beaucoup rigolé je crois on a
beaucoup parce que je vais faire
vous avez vu pour mon émission sur
iPhone use qui sera dimanche d'ailleurs
regarde et elle m'a raconté à cette
cette occasion que vous avez rigolé dans
on a pleuré
voilà
il est en couple télévisuels et vraiment
je peux vous dire qu'il y avait Gilles
intervenu d'ailleurs
non je voudrais juste regarder un truc
parce que on montre un truc c'est le
discours de Benoît Magimel qui a été
encore meilleur acteur pour la deuxième
année etc alors tous les relous ça fait
une mini polémique à cause de l'affaire
Palma donc
le César du meilleur acteur est attribué
à Benoît Magimel il réussit un carton
plein de César pour deux dominations en
cette catégorie totalement irréel c'est
encore mieux la troisième fois je crois
que ça c'est
voilà merci
franchement c'est beau ça fait vraiment
du bien et
ce soir est un moment assez assez
fou et voilà je suis très touché je veux
dire à mon père ce soir sur César et
puis merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
et bravo à lui